we are now literally only two days away
from apple's wwdc event and i am
extremely hyped because we are very
likely to see some hardware reveals or
even some releases so in this video i'm
basically gonna go through all the leaks
for the upcoming mac pro and the
upcoming redesigned m2 macbook air and
talk about which one of those two is the
most likely to be revealed so before i
jump right in and start talking about
the chances of a mac pro being revealed
or released i want to mention that luke
miani just tweeted out that he is a
hundred percent sure that there will be
some hardware at
wwdc now he wouldn't necessarily count
on being able to buy it right away but
he's 100 sure that some hardware is
being announced now in terms of the mac
pro leaks i do believe that we should be
seeing it very soon definitely this year
because at apple's last event which was
in march apple teased the apple silicon
mac pro saying that they still have to
talk about it here listen for yourself
making our transition nearly complete
with just one more product to go mac pro
there you go he just teased the mac pro
saying that the apple silicon transition
is nearly complete and since it's a
two-year transition it should be here
sometime this year now some of the leaks
go way back to december of last year
when mark german said that apple is
planning five new macs for 2022
including a new mac pro with apple
silicon now going even further back in
may of 2021 mark grumman was saying that
the apple silicon mac pro may feature up
to 32 high performance cores in a 128
core option for the graphics so it's
basically going to be a 40 core with 32
high performance and 8 efficiency cores
and of course we haven't seen this ship
yet because the current m1 ultra chip is
only a 20 core it's actually two m1 max
dies put together which is codenamed
jade 2c die and what makes this
interesting is that mark german leaked
the jade foresee die which is basically
four of the m1 maxes put together to
create the 40 core chip that he's
talking about right here and the
craziest part of all is that shrimp
apple pro recently leaked a bunch of
different chip information and he
confirmed that the m1 extreme or the
jade 4c die does exist so it's not some
kind of leak that didn't happen it
actually exists out there somewhere and
apple is likely testing it right now and
adding on to that we actually got some
links from majin buu who said based on
his sources here's some official
information on the new mac pro 2022 yes
this year he showed a bridge that
connects two m1 ultra chips together to
create the jade 4c die and it's going to
be found in the 2022 mac pro he says the
processor's name is redfern and he says
they're going to be coming with the new
mac pros this september which is a very
interesting release date because it
doesn't really make sense for an apple
event to be in september except for the
iphone event so that would mean apple
would need an event first to reveal the
mac pro before releasing it later which
it only makes sense to be wwdc and as
you can see in this image we can see the
ultrafusion links combining four
different dyes right over here in this
corner however the really weird thing is
that mark german later tweeted out that
this is what he's expecting apple's mac
lineup to look like by the end of 2023
and that includes a mac pro with an m2
ultra and m2 extreme so that's based on
the m2 instead of the m1 and he even
says that the m2 extreme is gonna have
48 cpu cores potentially which is sounds
crazy and 96 or 128
graphic scores so he says they might
actually base it on the m2 chip instead
and then in april he said that apple is
testing at least nine new macs with four
different m2 chip variants and that
included a couple of macbook pros with
the m2 pro and m2 max chips and a mac
pro that will include a successor to the
m1 ultra used in the max studio so i
don't know if that means an m2 ultra or
an m2 extreme i personally think he does
mean the extreme model but i do want to
remind everybody that apple could
totally call it a different chip name
for example the x1 to kind of put it
into a different more advanced category
or class now going further mcguire wood
on twitter said that he believes the mac
pro may get a teaser but will not see a
full announcement so it kind of matches
up to imagine boo's leak where it could
come in september or maybe even later
but it could get an actual teaser at
wwdc
and that's exactly what mark gruman said
way back in january saying that i don't
believe the mac pro will be released at
wwdc rather announced and he says that
because he believes that the apple
silicon transition should be finished
out by june and that's gonna happen by
announcing or teasing the mac pro and
that brings me to a tweet from sami
fathy who said that the mac pro and
studio display pro could get previewed
at wwdc with an entirely new series of
apple silicon chip and that's more
likely to him than the macbook air and
he also once again mentioned that the
mac pro will not have an m series chip
but it could be something like the z1 or
an x1 which i also agree with and if you
don't know where that studio display pro
idea came from it's actually from ross
young who's a very reliable analyst in
terms of displays he said he's still
expecting a 27 inch mini led display
from apple in june and he said it could
be called the studio display pro and he
says production has already started on
the display and then i asked him if it
could be alongside a new mac pro and he
said yes that is our thinking so he
thinks it could get revealed the mac pro
and the display at wwdc
however recently he just came out and
said that the 27-inch monitor has been
delayed as it was being produced at
quanta in shanghai which has been locked
down so he thinks it now looks like an
october release instead of a september
release and you never know maybe apple
is just going to hold onto it until
later on in the fall or maybe even
december like they did in the past with
the mac pro however there was ming chi
kuo who came out earlier this year and
said that he believes the mac pro is not
coming until
2023 which kind of sounds insane to me
because if you think about it apple did
tease the mac pro at the spring event so
imagine if they teased it and literally
didn't say anything for an entire year
until 2023 that would just be kind of
like click bait and it would be very
annoying so i do think that at wwdc
we're going to be getting a mac pro
teaser but not the full announcement and
with that said let's jump into the leaks
for the redesigned m2 macbook air now
going all the way back to january of
2021 mark german leaked the thinner and
lighter high-end macbook air with max
safe that could launch in the second
half of 2021
which obviously did not happen because
we're now in 2022 now so i think it's
getting very very close but the point
about the high-end macbook air that i
want to highlight is i think that the
regular m1 macbook air could stick
around in the lineup at the same price
or maybe 900 bucks and then this new m2
redesigned macbook air is going to be
available at a higher price maybe around
1200 bucks and getting into the actual
design details it was rumored that it's
going to be featuring a notch design
just like the 14 and 16 inch macbook pro
and just to give that some proof if we
go to ross young's leak from march he
said that the 2022 macbook air will have
an increased display size from 13.3
inches to 13.6 which to me basically
confirms the notch by adding a little
bit more vertical pixel space at the top
just like they did with the 14.2 inch
and 16.2 inch macbook pros because of
the notch and then back in march
mingxiko gave us some new updated leaks
in terms of the 2022 macbook air saying
that it's first of all going to be mass
produced in late second quarter of 22
which is at the end of june which means
it's totally possible for us to see the
release at wwdc he said it's going to
have no mini led display an all new form
factor design more color options and
weirdly he thinks it could have an m1
chip which to me made absolutely zero
sense so i completely ignored that m1
chip leak because going further mark
german confirmed that the redesigned
macbook air is gonna have an m2 chip and
he expects the m2 chip to have an eight
core cpu like the m1 but with a nine
core or 10 core gpu so two more gpu
cores for the basic m2 and then going
further there was actually evidence of
the m2 chip within some software that
was spotted ahead of the march event and
that was for an eight core cpu and a 10
core gpu and then once again that brings
us back to the leak from mark german
saying that nine new macs with four
different m2 chip variants are coming
including a macbook air with an m2 chip
with an a core cpu and 10 core gpu now
that is why i don't believe in manche
quo's leak where he said that it could
just have an m1 chip which did not make
sense to me at all however there was a
tweet from chance miller saying that
minchiko told him that the m1 could be a
modified version of the existing n1 and
that the actual m2 could be pushed to
2023
and really it just comes down to
marketing names and we all know apple's
history there so what if the m2 that
he's talking about the actual m2 is
gonna become the m3 and this modified m1
is gonna actually become marketed as the
m2 which is why minchi quo could have
messed that up in terms of his leak and
that brings me to a huge leak from
shrimp apple pro saying that the a16
chip and the m2 chip could be stuck
using the same a15 chip technology which
is tsmc's
n5p as you can see right here and this
basically confirms that it's going to be
using 2nd gen 5 nanometer which is the
same technology that the a15 is based on
and he confirmed that it's not only
gonna be the a16 but also the m1x
question mark whatever the name is chip
that's gonna be modified which he then
came back and said his sources agree
that the m1x could actually be the m2
chip instead which is exactly what i
have been saying with four high
performance cores for efficiency cores
and 10 apple gpu cores so this could be
a huge upgrade from the m1 and that's
going to be the modified m1 which is
going to be branded as the m2 and the
real m2 is going to get delayed until
2023 and titled the m3 and the crazy
thing about that leak is that it
actually confirms a different leak from
november of 2021 from the information
and their report said that the second
generation chips will use an upgraded
version of the five nanometer process
used for the m1 m1 pro and m1 max which
is exactly what minshi kuo told chance
miller and they went on to say that the
second generation chip with just one die
will be included in the long rumored
redesigned macbook air as well as in
some ipads and that ship is code named
statin now that is very very important
because a few months later in march of
this year 995 mac came out with an
exclusive leak saying that a new macbook
air and 13-inch macbook pro with the m2
chip are coming later this year and they
said that the macbook air is codenamed
j413 and it's gonna feature the m2 chip
which is internally known as
statin so there's that name once again
and here's the craziest thing they said
it's based on the a15 chip which i
didn't want to believe but shrimp apple
pearl basically confirmed that it's
based on the a15 and i do want to
mention that they said that a new mac
mini with the m2 could be coming this
year as well and that brings us to
another leak from april where samsung
was going to be helping apple with the
m2 chip and the crazy thing to notice
here is that they said it's expected
that apple will introduce the m2
processor in the first half of the year
which is before july so it would be
perfect for a wwdc
reveal and just to add the nail in the
coffin mark german came out with a
report saying that the m2 macbook air is
going to be among the most likely wwdc
hardware announcements and he added that
if there's any hardware at wwdc it'll
likely be on the mac's side with apple
aiming to launch the next macbook air
with m2 chips at the conference despite
some of the supply chain issues that are
going on and he did say that developers
say that apple employees are
increasingly using next generation
macbook airs with their apps which is a
sign that the new mac is close and this
finally brings me to a leak thread by
geo riku mcguire wood saying that the
macbook air refresh is happening at wwdc
with new colors and modified chassis
design slightly larger battery with the
m2 chip no face id in the top display
camera area this year which basically
confirms the notch is coming battery
life is going to be improved compared to
the current m1 macbook pro which is
actually very good thanks to improved
efficiency of the new m2 chip and this
is basically the final nail in the
coffin that wraps up all the other leaks
and rumors that leads me to say that i
am 100 confident that an m2 macbook air
is coming at wwdc
and in terms of the mac pro i do agree
with maguire wood saying that we could
get a one more thing type of teaser but
i don't think we'll be getting a full
announcement and there's a chance that
it could be announced later or it could
just come out in december who really
knows so we'll have to see but the m2
macbook air is in the bag i believe so
if you totally disagree with me then
comment down below but if you enjoyed
this video click the circle above to
subscribe because wwdc is going to be
amazing and we're going to be covering
everything that comes out definitely
check out one of those two videos right
there thanks for watching and we'll see
you in the next video
[Music]